for decades the Soyuz rocket has been a
workhorse allowing humans to escape
their cradle earth fail-proof
for more than 30 years until this
cognitive knowledge to be a pet produced
sobriety
my pet pagodas - goodness now
options
special ability
[Music]
two people on board one of them on his
maiden flight rescue teams watched the
capsule descend with nothing more than
pure of faith that austere Nord Nick
Hague and cosmonaut Alexei of Chinon
were okay we're standing by for
information as we continue to get it
from the Russian flight control team but
everything seems to be fine with the
crew we had could come with them and
they are okay
[Music]
relief unimaginable in scale for most
became real for the families of the crew
Esmeraude of Chileans wife spoke to me
moments after learning her husband was
doing well kusmanov Tov canoes Nagato at
tsunami who disappear survives a new
catchable shows Kazakh spicy bus passes
ilium top ribbon all sistemas Passini
blog ad area even naturally better
Bernoulli's Nazim lives usually mini
bridge Amamiya many called it's a
miracle but professionals called it
impeccable performance of the soyuz
rescue system you see the capsule
carrying the crew this one is basically
a small rocket built into the larger one
so use during an emergency the rescue
module takes away the capsule separating
it from the Soyuz here's how it works
[Music]
she knows review delicious at the kakero
second approved of some annuity mr. Pete
Licata emerges by still a vehicle
there was a sordid love
the cheesy
a dozen a result of the president's top
and
tonight Somali territorial power each
group what I see required to provide a
presence
[Music]
investigators checked every entity and
person who as much as laid a finger on
the soyuz and eventually pinned the
blame on the rocket assembly defect but
the reason behind the failure was
operational the accident occurred you to
a fault in a sensor this could only
happen at the Assembly stage at the
Baikonur cosmodrome
but while the probe was underway it was
clear with only three crew out of the
required six stationed on the ISS it had
to be manned and fast the ISS has
entered 2019 with a full house the new
crew successfully launched in December
even a bit earlier than scheduled in two
months after the incident the new crew
was unfazed I went inside feeling
absolutely safe it is a bit small as an
Italian I wish that maybe Ferrari
take part in the design but in a way
witnessing that event to me was actually
reassuring in the smart design or the
Soyuz and the incredible work that the
surgeon does to people here on the
ground that can do our ready to do every
everywhere
[Music]
it was a nick or Alexei but they are set
for round two in just a couple of months
and with this still being a maiden
flight for Nick Hague they are both as
excited as ever
you